- Welcome back everybody!
We have Daniel Radcliffe and
Jane Krakowski on the line.
They are both actually in the new
"Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt:
Kimmy vs. the Reverend"
now on Netflix., you gotta check it out.
Because the new "Kimmy Schmidt" episode
is about making choices,
and because Twitter forces tough
questions upon us everyday,
Daniel, Jane, and I are going to deal
with some of those very tough choices,
in a little segment called,
Kelly's Quaran Twitter Questionnaire.
(upbeat pop music)
I'll read some of the most
liked and retweeted questions
on twitter in the last month,
then we will all get to answer.
So, our first Twitter question
is from @theyearofelan
"Your quarantine nickname
is how you feel right now
"plus the last thing you
ate out of a cupboard."
Okay Jane, you go, ladies first, go ahead.
- Okay, mine would be hopeful Nut Thins.
- (laughs) That's amazing!
Daniel, what's yours?
- I was gonna say, mine
I guess would be like,
contented honey roasted almonds.
It's quite long.
- I like that though.
- Okay, mine is overwhelmed
red velvet cake. (laughs)
(laughing)
But, you know what, you
usually do feel overwhelmed
when you eat too much
of it, a friend told me,
I obviously haven't eaten too much.
All right, so next question,
next twitter question is from @GifMario.
"Who is your racer of choice
in Mario Kart on Nintendo 64?"
Daniel, what's yours?
You're the gamer.
- I was never very good at it,
but I think that character
that I always liked
playing as the most was Yoshi.
- I love Yoshi!
- I think I would go with that
just because he was cute and fun.
- Yeah, Yoshi was cool.
- (mumbles).
- That would've been mine, Yoshi's mine.
What's yours Jane, have
you ever played Mario Kart?
- (laughs) I've never played it.
I somehow, did not get into
the video games thing at all,
and I know, with kids, the kid pressure,
my son hasn't really gotten
into them yet either,
I'm like sorta trying to slow that down,
but so like, I'll take Yoshi too (laughs).
- Yoshi's awesome!
Yoshi's, It's a fun one.
Okay, this next one was
posted by @movingsideways,
"You are quarantined with the first artist
"you saw in concert.
"Who is it?"
- Daniel, I'll let you go first.
- Well, the first band I
went to see was The Strokes.
Which is quite cool, but,
the actual real answer
which is that a concert I was
taken to when I was like 10
would be the Pet Shop Boys.
So, it would be me and the Pet Shop Boys.
- Wow!
Those are both pretty cool.
- Yeah, they're both pretty cool.
- Yeah, okay, you're cool, whatever, cool.
What was yours Jane?
- Mine's a little more
Jersey, where I was raised.
Mine is Van Halen. (laughs)
- Oh that's amazing! (laughs)
- [Daniel] That would be
a hell of a quarantine.
- So me and David Lee Roth
like dancing on our table,
like, I guess, I don't know. (laughs)
- Your quarantine's gonna be a good time!
That's amazing-
- My house is gonna be trashed!
(laughing loudly)
What's yours Kelly?
- Mine,
I honestly can't remember,
I know this sounds funny,
I can't remember, it was either,
this is gonna sound funny,
but it was either the Toadies,
which is my favorite band of all time,
it's a Texas band, they're alternative.
Or, it's Celine Dion,
so I don't know which one it is. (laughs)
But I think, she'd be a hell
of a good time in a quarantine,
because
- I think so too.
I don't know if you've seen her on stage,
but she is crazy funny.